on vous parlait hier de l'importance de
la prévention contre les noyades
nouvelle illustration dramatiques des
risques encourus par les jeunes enfants
au bord de l'eau la chute accidentelle
hier d'un garçon de 3 ans dans la
rivière Indre à Esvres il a été
hospitalisé dans un état critique alors
comment expliquer ce drame et réduire
les risques d'accidents au maximum le
reportage sur place de Clémence dose
qu'avec
une enquête a été ouverte suite à ce
qu'il s'est passé ici à Esvres sur Inde
plus précisément à la prairie de forges
c'était lundi aux alentours de 19h un
garçon de 3 ans et demi est tombé dans
l'Indre il aurait échappé à la vigilance
de ses parents dérivera alertés par
l'écrit se sont rendus sur place et en
contactait un pompier volontaire
plusieurs minutes se sont écoulées et
l'enfant a été retrouvé à 4 mètres de
l'endroit où il a chuté il aurait passé
plusieurs minutes sous l'eau selon le
maire de la commune aucun accident de ce
type n'est jamais arrivé ici les gens
viennent pique-niquer pêcher sur les
bordelins alors c'est bien que bien que
la baignade soit interdite j'ai des
jeunes qui se baignent dans l'Indre mais
on n'a jamais eu d'accidents de noyade
l'un de c'est pas un étang il y a des
courants dans l'Indre première cause
d'accidents domestiques chez les moins
de 25 ans la noyade fait plus de 500
enfants victimes chaque été en
intervention le temps des pompiers est
compté pour les secourir les enfants
n'ont pas forcément la conscience du
danger s'il chute dans l'eau ils vont
être à gare
ils vont au niveau de leur motricité ils
m'ont pas essayé de revenir à la surface
en fait ils vont se laisser couler et du
fait de la visibilité qui est pas
forcément terrible dans nos rivières du
département
on peut vite perdre de vue l'enfant qui
tombe à l'eau la saison estivale se
profile et avec elle la volonté de se
rapprocher des plans d'eau pour se
rafraîchir comme chaque année le
gouvernement
est de prévention contre les noyades
avec un mot d'ordre si vous tenez à eux
ne les quittez pas des yeux